I'm Tyler I'm a stripper with the
Hollywood men hi my name is Egypt Black
Nile and I am known as the golden girl
of burlesque
it just kind of happened so fast I went
buck wild I got super excited so many
girls there I ran into a couple of guys
that I went to high school in and to see
those guys who were older than me in
there it was a very horrifying
experience but after that it was
wonderful
they went into a bag of - seeing all the
g-strings and the bikinis and it was
actually my grandfather who noticed
because he washed everything in the
house he asked me you know what are you
doing my family has always been
supportive I actually called them and I
didn't know exactly the reaction to say
I've gone with the Hollywood men to
dance waiting for the reaction and my
family totally supported it they asked
once every other show at least I thanked
him for the offer but say I don't do
that
I get propositioned for sex by men and
women it really doesn't bother me it
really comes with the territory
I handle them by saying no
they ran out of money so I cut off her
chicken tenders and and I said thank you
but I'm good and they went to the ATM
machine I came back and I also ate the
chicken tenders they're actually really
good
I had another male exotic dancer say to
me I want to drink your bathwater even
after you pee in it who's out there my
bathwater
I don't get aroused in orgasmic way my
arousal is more of a mental type arousal
I'll call it the mindfuck there's always
those special few girls that get me
going to say the least so every night I
get aroused absolutely
I will never refuse a dance for anybody
that smells bad or looks bad ever the
only time I'll refuse is if they go too
much touching or if they're just too
drunk I have refused to dance for a guy
and a woman actually because their
hygiene wasn't up to par looks No I
don't care what you look like the most
that I have ever made probably was about
eight or nine thousand dollars and it
was a birthday night the most ever got
in one night was 3.5 K it was awesome it
is difficult to be in a relationship for
most people we like that connection and
our interaction with the ladies but it
is still a job and sometimes the
significant other doesn't realize that
we know that you know the only thing
that I hate is when people try to change
you either you're with me or you're not
a majority of time they think they're
with me and then after a while they're
not in it anymore it's about how you
take the clothes off not just take your
clothes off the stigma I don't think it
sticks for everyone if you're an
individual and you have morals and
values and you grew up a certain way you
won't follow the leader you will be the
leader teaching in a pole studio I
noticed a lot of women who are older you
should see the way they release and they
enjoy their sexuality and they become
sexy and Aidan
no they had all this sexiness if people
open up and stop being so stuffy and
stop judging and being judgmental about
stripping or whatever it is in life I
think we can overcome anything the end
of day who cares what people think if
you like it go do it
[Music]